what we're going to do in this video is
describe how our perceptions of public
opinion may or may not affect policy
decisions so what I have here is an
excerpt from an article on Politico that
was published at the end of February
shortly after the shootings in Florida
and it says support for stricter gun
laws has spiked in polls conducted after
the fatal South Florida school shooting
hitting its highest level in at least a
quarter century roughly two and three
Americans now say gun control laws
should be made more strict in the wake
of the murder of seventeen people at
Marjory Stoneman Douglas High School
according to a number of polls including
a new Politico morning consult poll that
shows support for stricter gun laws
among registered voters at 68 percent
compared with just 25 percent who oppose
stricter gun laws so if there was just a
direct connection between what we're
seeing in the polls and policy well then
you might expect stricter gun laws and
you could imagine there are many policy
makers who are already in support of
stricter gun laws who would use this
data to further their argument why say
Congress should pass more legislation to
make stricter gun laws but an
interesting question is why this still
might be an uphill battle in terms of
making stricter gun laws well you could
imagine there are other policy makers
members of Congress who won they may or
may not trust the poll data here maybe
they don't view it as a truly
representative sample others might say
hey this is a temporary trend that's
driven by the graphic nature of the news
surrounding these polls others might say
hey look this might be the national
numbers I believe this poll and it might
not even be a temporary trend but they
say this is representative of the entire
country the polling numbers in my
district might be different now another
reason why a policymaker
despite this type of national poll may
not want to vote in favor of stricter
gun laws is that their political
calculus might not favor it for example
even if their constituents support
stricter gun laws most of their
constituents might not be so activated
about that they might care more about
the
like the economy and they might have a
smaller subset say the 25% who oppose
stricter gun laws who are willing to
vote on that issue and it might do more
harm to your political chances to upset
that group on this issue than to a try
to appeal to the majority on the issue
and the last reason why a policymaker
may not be in support of it even though
public opinion seems to be is that they
view the issue as being more subtle and
more nuanced than maybe they think that
the broader public might appreciate that
yes when you see something horrific like
this you want to regulate it more you
want to pass laws but there could be
policymakers who believe that those laws
won't be effective or they might not
have the intended consequences but it's
an interesting question when public
opinion affects policy decisions and
when it doesn't